[Music]
he's like he's like you need the camera
you need a record this we're in Atlanta
where you are in know Reba and I was
just talking to my cousin Jenny cuz I'm
so excited to see her but we're here for
playlist live whatever but my cousin
Jenny she's like pregnant again she's
gonna have a baby boy and we're not
gonna be able to see her tonight but
hopefully and the time that we're here
we get to see that but but as of right
now we are eating some Cuban food cuz
you can't come to Florida and not have
Cuban food so true
[Music]
so it's the night before the events
begins or here trying to get our passes
oh this place is so confusing we don't
know where we're going and I really
gotta pee
we know it's playlist live they look at
all the logos I'm just waiting for one
of us to bump into something
[Music]
grab a medium for me look we get all
this free time
okay small if it's too big I just wear
for pyjamas yeah actually I don't know I
think he's over this maybe but all for
eating
Oh 480 net there we go I want the Logan
berry Logan like what like I don't want
to take it I don't know what it's for
all I know is if I take everything from
this - right here it's just going into
the trash one week from now so I'm not
gonna grab anything at all maybe we are
checking into our Airbnb finally yet
11:52 p.m. yeah you get to choose we're
not doing about seniority wise yeah
we're at the bottom of the barrel we're
at the bottom we're talking about
picking rooms we get last pick last pick
since we're not feeding any other bosses
so we're like oh we're waiting for just
to make your pick sighs where's our
shower this one hmm Oh actually kind of
like this room cute
there it is right if we fight oh that's
so cute the kids yeah hey what's in here
oh my god how cute this door is random
like it looks like an actual lake
there's someone with really long legs
are really short body step up this way
they're gonna be a part of my family for
the weekend they're actors I rented them
for the weekend
we are the Jitsu Kawas well I feel like
chery chery yeah no that's very
particular you want him to keep it a
model home we need one of these Mazetti
but it's break down your ladle or
whatever you're cooking with oh yeah
yeah we do need that
[Music]
oh look looks right here
oh no it's Heidi - our - yeah Oh nice
walk down the hallway oh thanks so far
you know okay good morning first morning
in Orlando and Bart's ready to go work
out when ozl you gotta show them our
friends they're outside oh yeah we made
friends yes I'm trying to post it on the
story when I found them because I was
standing out here in the morning just
like soaking in the Orlando air and then
I see them hanging out across the what
is this like a pond yeah right it's like
a pond anyway I saw them hanging out
across the way and then I look away I
was looking at this guy and the next
thing I know I looked this way to my
right and then I see what this guy right
here walking straight towards me and I
started freaking out and I'm like oh my
god and cuz at that moment I was taking
this boomerang that I'm trying to upload
so I was like doing them for Murray
another place any time I get brighter
so that boomerang right there and then
it sound like I was still trying to post
yeah okay it won't pose so I don't know
if you guys are gonna see it on my D or
not I'm trying to post it and then I
look over and I'm like oh my gosh she's
right here oh my god I'm like that was
buzz like just save and cancel I'll do
this later
and then I saw
like recording this duck and I'm like
freaking out inside because I'm like I'd
wanted to attack me but then it turned
out to be a really nice duck and then Jo
and Bart we're feeding it bagels all
morning and then he called his homies
over and now they're just chilling here
[Music]
like any wag their tails - it's so cute
it's like their dogs we have the ones
standing right here staring at us
that's the ones that was being said
they're doing a circuit inside the house
you're breakdancing you guys are so
athletic you have to work out even on
vacation so while they're doing all of
that let's check on quick duck friends
they're all sleeping okay
you have an itch behind your wing all
right I gotta get ready now but I
finally want to upload my whole story
you guys what is happening that's going
on are you choking dude what's happening
what's happening look forget to choking
like what it's activate I think maybe
that's the leader and it's telling
everyone all right guys I think it's
time for us to bounce maybe not no one
else is moving anymore nevermind I don't
know how to interpret tickling your what
I think our mission
oh sorry I'm trying to give you strength
here voice um going to view more like
rust your suit come on baby let's do
this let's go you finish bite
good job
[Music]
please live with the whole crew you be
exciting or you check it out see what
this is all about and get some free
stuff
cuz that's deep what's up baby how are
you doing pretty good good to see you
man I'm ready for day one this is day
one we've never done because of you yes
I'm the old a for a veteran I'm the guy
with a pipe who's looking out in the
distance he's like yes you know a lot of
these but that's why I wanted you here
so guys there's a group of great people
here but it's mostly terrible people
it's like an ecosystem for like people
who get popped up eating Tide Pods and
then walking around being now it is so
we decided to come later Steve but then
it turns out that you're gonna come and
so you like play with our emotions you
think I'm not gonna go I am gonna go I'm
not gonna go like it we're gonna believe
you anymore until we see you in our land
Cheers
[Music]
for that much just met master Wang and
he's like this kung fu master on YouTube
that teaches like self-defense
he's into it oh man I don't think I've
ever been starstruck like that before
oh yeah so yeah the camera right at his
hands and I'm like what are you doing
start recording press record and you're
like
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
compared to what I imagine that it would
be like but apparently today not even
officially the first day apparently
tomorrow is when everything that's it
backwards it backwards
[Music]
[Music]
honestly I feel like we're walking
around all day and I don't know what I'm
doing all right
backstage that's how you know it's
backstage when you see plates
[Music]
what's Tigers favorite color
[Laughter]
huh
[Music]
so Steve supposed to be our veteran tour
guide of playlist live and clearly he
does not know what he's doing we just
got in trouble for for going to random
rooms now now we are at the Orlando Eye
is that what this place is called
Legoland I don't know that's how I see
Legoland
what the where the ferris wheel is and
we are about to meet his family
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Mexican how do you feel about yes or no
that's not a Mexican thing that's at
their American yeah melted cheese that's
all it is
I thought this was like legit Mexican
food thrown up cousin
[Music]
[Music]
baby fever you're surrounded by baby are
you ready to be a big brother I'm not
ready to be a big brother
[Music]
[Music]
all going good I'm almost going to
college I want to hear the song face
face don't be afraid
what's a little band that's so true now
you're gonna notice it sing it
they didn't give up my cover now I get
more bored than honor yeah sing me your
graduation song eat it and then you can
watch it on your phone it was so funny
sure I know is post my stories
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
shai good job good job had my vibe yes I
was posting on my story earlier no so
funny cuz you were just saying like
really loudly he's like this is you this
is you you was holding a phone with our
vlog playing in the background so he
watches us he's our number one fan
that's so sweet
Thank You Aidan I know you're gonna be
watching this later you need the camera
you need to record this
[Music]
thinking maybe a party boy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I gotta be my new name
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so we left that party and I know what
the nice thing that I ate Waffle House
at least like twice a week there Oh like
I'm gonna give another truck yeah
I don't think in his mind since you guys
married now his memories are yours
you know does you guys are married his
memories are yours
I speak with my hands what about you
aqua how's the green I grew up here and
Waffle House particularly Papa houses
are our teleportation size and we could
go for a walk miles to Waffle House I'm
gonna pull me out of home
do you like what Ellis and then my dad
will buy ya all this stuff is good on
the menu but the real star of the menu
is not even on the menu is actually the
porch otters and I've tried the pork
chop one time I was like oh these are
the bombs for whatever breakfast died
and so but you can actually get a pork
chop breakfast even though it doesn't
say it here menu then I know why they
used to be on the menu though Oh get off
old many secrets like some sense is
gonna be on this menu the other time
okay what they're feeling
I like it's all about to enjoy this
waffle though
[Music]
[Music]
No
what are you gonna do what are you do
[Laughter]
[Music]